fifth career start going up against
philadelphia
currently two and one with the 338 era
eight walks 30 strikeouts it was nice
for him to get his win
his first win of the season against the
mets in his last start we talked about
how well he pitched in that ball game
i think each game that's got
incrementally better remember all those
games he played with
pittsburgh and he swings at the first
pitch and lifts it to center
gaza's got it one pitch one out
another slider and that's the first
strikeout of the night
and then ended up in the other batters
box two outs
just underway and he got him on a slider
what a great
start for harbaugh there's velasquez
an era of nine he's thrown four innings
has struck out nine that's good
but he's walked eight that's not good
vince kicks and comes home in the pitch
swung on and foul tipped hung onto by
rio muto
runner goes pitches bounce toward third
balm's only play is to first
and he's able to throw out trevor story
vince checks second here's the pitch
swinging the ground ball right side
right at nick maton he'll throw it to
first and there's a scoreless
first inning for vince velasquez now go
to the second inning
no score jt road muto the 1-0 and a
swing and a drive will hit to right
field going back on it
is blackman he pulls up at the wall it
bangs off the out-of-town scoreboard
jt on his way into second blackman picks
it up jt trying for third here's the
throw it's not in time
and j.t romuto with a triple
off the 14-foot high wall in right d.d
back in the lineup after missing the
series with the giants
and a bouncer right side jt will score
it'll be an rbi for gregorius and the
phillies take a one-nothing lead
they're tremendous players everywhere
there's a strikeout third of the game
swung on and missed so a triple by
remove to an rbi ground out the phillies
after an inning and a half leading one
nothing
is jewel cabrera yeah yeah 2-1
swinging a ground ball left side
backhand boom he's got it spins fires to
second
and they get one there maton dropped it
pulling it out of the glove and uh
kind of an awkward step across the bag
he got tripped up a little bit
but did get the out there at second base
and velasquez ready here's the pitch
swinging a miss he struck him out went
to back to that change up
the pitch swung on lined up the middle
there's a base knock for vince velasquez
back in 2005. next pitch is wrapped on
the ground to short to his right story
fires to hampson for one on to first
cut the double play last year the
shortened season
swing and a miss as marquez went
breaking ball again
nunez will fire down to first and airman
marquez winds up facing the minimum
in the third pretty good looking swing
he just had
swinging a miss he was tardy oh that
swing three strikeouts for velasquez
3-2 and this is hit the shallow
center with a drop it will first hit for
the rockies
[Applause]
bouncer back toward the middle that
should be two there's one and an easy
double play
three scoreless innings for vince
velasquez
a little floater out toward center field
that's going to drop in for a hit
harper's on his way to third
first and third with nobody out
former diamondback and he breaks the bat
and crow nearly scrambled to tag
real muto out here is alec baum
[Applause]
a little tapper again left of the mouth
it's going to get a run home
the throw to first is in time but it's
an rbi for bulm it's two nothing
phillies so now jt's at third and here's
nick maton
and a roller to chrome and he'll flip to
her
he gets the out story a 5-3 ground ball
his first time
1-1 on story high drive deep left field
will it get out home run story
and the drought is over september
17th of last year was the last time he
hit one
gets a change up that's running it
you're right he didn't get that on the
barrel but he's so
strong the way the the hands connected
with the body
walked his first time one out in the
fourth velasquez now has
his sign and the payoff pitch swing and
a high fly ball this is deep to right
center field
moving back to the wall harper looking
up he will not get it
gone home runs cj crone
and the rockies tie the game at two on a
big blast to right
that's home runs at six out of the last
seven ball games 92 miles an hour
and he made velasquez pay first and
third one out with hoskins coming up
nunez to the outside corner
slider got it for the third time this is
the drama that you want in baseball you
got one of the best pitchers out there
you got one of the best sitters
3-2 in the air center field
playable for gaza
job well done by hermond
broken back base hit to right
and story thinking two the whole way
will have it easily
you start the sixth inning a 2-2
ballgame jeremiah marquez still on the
mound
swung on and missed strikeout number
seven
for herman he's
got him went with a changeup
well done him on marcus
oh the picture right now to one pitch
swung on and hit in the air to center
plenty deep enough you would think
waiting on it is dazza he makes the
catch he uncorks the throw here's
gonna be cut off and roman quinn will
slide home safely with
the go-ahead run on a sac fly by
andrew mccutchen and the phillies lead
at three to two reese hoskins over three
[Applause]
and he sends one of the air to deep left
center field going back is dazza it
is gone a home run for reese hoskins his
fourth of the year
the phillies add another one on top four
to two
he jumps on this first pitch and he
crushes it to left center
almost dead center here bullpen still
has an era
close to five this year this is up the
middle
top spinner will get through sam
hilliard with the great speed
he'll get to third easily first and
third colorado
with one out
up the middle base hit top here's going
to go first to third
rockies within a run ryan mcmahon
coming through here come the rockies
so now charlie blackman with two outs
at this these critical times
foul territory searching and makes the
catch
he pushed the net back and grabbed it
and that will end
the bottom of the seventh inning great
play garrett hampson a single in three
tries this ball hit the air to deep left
fields got a chance
way back there she goes
tie ball game garrett hampson
with his second of the year
the heck with the single how about a big
fly
garrett hampson that's right at crone
there's one
on the first double play a lot of play
by
cj crowd there's rockies trying to win
it here in the bottom of the night one
out that'll bring up top here
oh ball deep right field did rymel do it
he did
rockies have won it right
tapia has walked off the fields